wir wollen jetzt weitermachen mit der
Frage was die Impfpflicht in unserem
Land gemacht hat und meine Meinung dazu
ist das ist der größte Wort vor und
möglicherweise schwerwiegendste
Wortbruch des Jahres ist jetzt hört man
immer von allen Politikern ja ja Meinung
dürfen sich ja ändern und die Situation
sei eben schlimmer als damals und
deswegen brauchen wir jetzt die
Impfpflicht und gleichzeitig muss man
sich das mal vorstellen hören wir das
möglicherweise nicht mal genügend
Impfstoff da ist für die Booster
Kampagne im nächsten Jahr wir hören dass
Politiker hausieren gehen unter anderem
Peter Tschentscher mit Zahlen der sagt
die ungeimpften sind an allem schuld
weil die Zahl besonders hoch sind er
musste sie sich jetzt korrigieren
genauso wie in Bayern ich finde dass die
Politiker einen schwerwiegenden Fehler
begangen haben in diesem Jahr in dem sie
die Impfpflicht kategorisch
ausgeschlossen haben wenn man gesagt
hätte im Sommer im Herbst momentan
wollen wir die Impfpflicht nicht wenn
wir eine bestimmte nicht erreichen dann
kann es aber passieren dass wir eine
Ehrlichkeit da hätte man diese nicht so
kategorisch ausgeschlossen ich glaube
jetzt ist dieser Wortbruch besonders
schlimm und zwar deshalb weil im Sommer
ich kann mich daran erinnern auch an die
Diskussionen und wenn man mit Kritik
angesprochen hat sie hatte gesagt kam ja
ja und am Ende ihr werdet sehen diese
Impfpflicht wird doch kommen und dann
wurde in Telegramm Kanälen geschwurbelt
und es wurde gesagt die Politik haben
damit angefangen wir werden dort am Ende
lang ich glaube wenn man sich anschauen
bei der Frage was diese Impfpflicht
Debatte auslöst dass sie am Ende viel
schädlicher ist für unser Land als wir
uns am Ende bringt ich glaube es ist
höchst gefährlich für die politische
Kultur in Deutschland das mittlerweile
alle umgekippt sind zumindest von den
Politikern die wichtig sind sogar der
Vorsitzende der FDP als Freiheitspartei
die SPD ist umgekippt und auch die
Grünen hatten das an ausgeschlossen für
mich ein folgenschwerer Wortbruch im
Jahr 2021 der uns 22 weiter beschäftigen
wird der Paul da gebe ich dir vollkommen
recht ich glaube es ist auch toxisch wie
Debatte die können wir ja gar nicht
öffnen weil wie du sagst die Parteien
sich ja in der Mitte alle einig was ich
auch sehr sehr schwierig finde weil
damit ist eigentlich sind viele meiner
Meinung nach noch vertretbare Positionen
Villar zur Impfung nein zu Impfpflicht
sind an den rechten Rand gerückt worden
wie findest du jetzt politisch Nummer
bei der AFD find ich ganz schwierig in
der FDP regt sich jetzt bisschen
Widerstand mit Kubicki und und einigen
anderen aber ich finde die öffentliche
Debatte ist komplett gespalten und des
reflektiert auch so bisschen was ist der
Bundestag signalisiert hat wenn ich mir
schaue für mich eigentlich neben der CDU
oder wahrscheinlich noch mehr der größte
Verlierer ist dieses Jahr eigentlich die
Freiheit wenn du wirklich stimmen die
sagen ja zur Impfung aber nein
Impfpflicht oder Jahr zu
Entscheidungsfreiheit wie die angegangen
werden auch honorige Menschen wie Frau
Passbilder oder am Richard David Brecht
alle die sie bisschen Gedanken machen
über die Freiheit nie geht diese Debatte
jetzt weiter was bedeutet er nimmt mich
dass du es doch debattieren und sagt es
uns nicht einfach so ja wir uns
entschieden wir sind jetzt alle verleben
Pflicht dass das mit unserer
Gesellschaft gemacht hat dieser Riss und
dieses wir diskutieren jetzt nicht
einmal mehr miteinander weil ihr habt es
ja gehört dass wird kommen darf glaube
ich diesen Riss wird die Gesellschaft
noch sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
lange Sprüche San Sebastian Villa wenn
wir darüber sprechen und man
wäre jetzt der Meinung und sag ich bin
gegen die Impfpflicht und man möchte
dafür auf die Straße gehen und dann
möchte seine Meinung sagen ich wüsste
gar nicht mehr wo man deine hingehen
soll weil man nämlich Angst haben muss
dass wenn man auf irgendeine Demo steht
wo vordergründig gesagt wird wir sind
gegen die Impfpflicht kommt man dann am
Ende neben
rechtsradikalen und andere steht also
diese sozusagen vernünftige Kritik und
die Debatte in Darmstadt findet erkenne
ich, auch wieder das ist eine sehr gute.
Weil ich habe mich immer gestört von
Anfang an ich habe ein paar von diesen
Demonstration tatsächlich live erlebt
und einmal durch Zufall in München war
das da ging sie ein Demonstrationszug
durch die Innenstadt und da habe ich
einfach mal geguckt wer ist da wer geht
da mit und so und es war wirklich
honorige Menschen das waren keine
schwurbler das waren keine
rechtsradikalen das war ein bisschen Öko
aber nicht nur dass man auch keine
Esoteriker wie Markus Söder immer sagt
mein Land ist voller Esoteriker deswegen
sind wir sowieso nicht schlecht mit den
Impfungen es von ganz normale Menschen
bürgerliche Menschen die sich einfach
Gedanken machen um das sind wer kann man
sagen ok sind auf dem falschen Dampfer
und das alles schlecht nur man kann
diese Menschen nicht in die Ecke stellen
mit mit rechtsradikalen und und und mit
mit mit Nazis das ist einfach unredlich
und deswegen brauchen wir diese Freiheit
auch für an das Denken in diesem Land
und noch einen respektablen Umgang mit
die
Lena für dich auch ein sehr emotionales
Thema du hast ganz viel auch über die
Impfpflicht in den vergangenen Monaten
gesprochen insbesondere Universitäten
und bestimmt Einrichtung wo die viele
geschrieben haben die sich da gegängelt
fühlen wie erlebst du die die politische
Debatte jetzt und was wird passieren aus
deiner Sicht wenn dann tatsächlich im
nächsten Jahr diese allgemeine
Impfpflicht kommt und dann am Ende 1000
€ Strafe darauf stehen wird das
irgendjemand überzeugen das schlimme ist
an der von den Debatten unserem Land
also erstens ist es ja so das muss man
ja den Politikern zu guter ein ich finde
schlimm in unserem Land aber viele
Menschen wollen ja die Impfpflicht also
ist ja nicht so als wenn du mir hat muss
man Soße
Graphen dann werden wir wieder darüber
berichten aber wir sind das schon so
sehr daran gewöhnt ich ich ich gucke
nicht mit mir heute hat niemand
geschrieben er darf jetzt in seinen
Führerschein nicht mehr machen weil er
geimpft weil er nicht geimpft ist er
deutet auch Zweig herrscht in den
Fahrstuhl ich kriege jeden Tag Briefe
von Menschen die irgendwo einige also
Gänge werden weil sich geimpft und
langsam muss ich auch sagen ich habe
mich schon selbst verschon so dran
gewöhnt gestern habe ich hier über Zweig
an den Tafeln gesprochenes i Tafel mona
hat sein gefüllte obdachlos und das
schlimme ist Paul gestern war wieder so
Moment wo ich wirklich so schlimm fand
aber das schlimmste ist für mich eine
aktuelle Debatte wir gewöhnen uns schon
so dran und deswegen fand ich was du
gesagt hast ganz ganz wichtig Sebastian
dass wir nicht aufhören dürfen auf dafür
zu kämpfen dass Menschen ist und da
fragen können und dass wir das tun Claus
Strunz hat ihr gesagt das fand ich sehr
spannend den Gedanken möchte ich noch
teilen dann beende ich meine Monolog er
hat Dir gesagt das Problem ist jetzt
auch gerade selbst wenn man
demonstrieren gehen wollen würde als ich
kann schon sagen ich glaube meine
Familie wäre es eine von denen das
wahrscheinlich tun würde wegen ihm zu
demonstrieren wo sollen wir das machen
weil wir wollen ja auch nicht mit
rechten dem Erfrieren das muss ich
ehrlich sagen und dementsprechend ich
mache mir ganz ganz große Sorgen um
unsere Demokratie und vielleicht wird es
irgendwann als der größte Fehler in die
Geschichte eingehen mit dem fliegt immer
noch irgendwo hingehen wenn man gegen
die Impfpflicht ist oder wird man dann
in die rechte Querdenker schwurbler Ecke
bestellt ich finde befinden uns fast in
den historischen
Situation habe ich heute geschafft zu
benutzen
wenn ich so durch den supermarkt
dann so eine freundliche Frauenstimme im
Hintergrund und der heißt es sie müssen
sich vergessen Sie nicht sie müssen sich
geimpft sein ich kam mir vor wie so ein
Ridley Scott Film ich kam mir vor wie so
ein Baby so empfinde bitte nnnn ein
Horrorfilm wo alle die sich die schöne
neue Welt und im Hintergrund flüstert
flüstert jemand Physik vergessen Sie
nicht Ihre Info vor paar Tagen habe ich
in den Weihnachtskarte gesehen auf der
Weihnachtskarte stand drauf aus Amerika
kam die Merry Christmas and don't forget
your Booster shot oder muss ich wirklich
sagen ich fand ich bin fertig bin aber
dabei
was wäre denn die Alternative am Tisch
hau dir drauf und sagen dann geht alles
richtig verstehe ja auch Leute die für
die Impfpflicht ziehen und ist die
Pandemie dauert so extrem lange und wir
sind doch alle auch schon so corone müde
und gerade in Deutschland wohne die
Maßnahmen nie gelockert das ist der
Unterschied zu Österreich kurzes deinen
anderen Weg gegangen wäre der wusste
immer ok ich machen harten Lockdown und
dann muss ich aber die Leute mal
rauslassen ihr wurde alles runter oder
machst du dann
natürlich
die meisten sind
70% in Deutschland
Verständnis
doch gesagt dass du so deinen den
Wechsel oder den Meinungsumschwung der
Politiker da durchaus verstehen kannst
mir ruhig aller Politiker ist wird er
mir hier so getan als wär das neue SPD
FDP und Grünen Jens Spahn hat für die
CDU ein Haus geerbt
und sein Leben hier in wird das
natürlich dass die drei die 30% ja das
ist genauso ein Problem ja da hast du
absolut Recht denn die Wissenschaft das
hat die Unsinn erzählt man darf ja nicht
mal Kritik an der Wissenschaft üben dann
wird mir sowieso auch gleichgesetzt mit
Querdenken dieses und ich mache sehr
kurz sind genau dann sind wir unser
Leben lang geschützt dann kam 2 + 1 aber
da draußen hat gesagt gibt's die
Aufzeichnung in DBA nur über 70 dann auf
einmal für alle aber im Abstand von 6
Monaten jetzt sogar zwei Monate auf
Impfung + 4 Wochen und da soll ich meine
Mutter geben da weiß ich wirklich nicht
mehr Bescheid was geht denn jetzt und
darf ich natürlich fragen also von der
mich auch verstehen